dell has just updated their XPS 13
laptop for 2019 and we got an
entry-level I 5 model for $1,150 which
is a great price considering it packs
eight gigabytes of RAM and 256 gigs of
nvme SSD storage so let's go through
everything you need to know about it
just like last year its encased in an
aluminum shell that looks and feels
great compared to many other Windows
laptops the display has very thin
great-looking bezels despite the fact
that they've moved the webcam back up
above the display last year's model had
the webcam under the display to
accommodate Windows hello a useful
feature that scans your face to log you
in without having to enter your password
that feature is now gone
but it's not a big deal since the power
button doubles as a fingerprint scanner
for logging in the display itself uses a
1080p panel that definitely isn't the
sharpest display out there but the
excellent color accuracy in the matte
filter make it one of the better 1080p
displays you can find but either way if
you care a lot about the display we'd
recommend upgrading to the 4k model for
a few hundred dollars more the keyboard
feels pretty decent for a Windows laptop
with a good amount of key travel typing
is pretty comfortable but some users did
complain that there was a bit too much
spacing between the keys personally we
prefer the latest MacBook Pro keys which
are wider and more clicky
but most people prefer the Dells it also
features backlighting with two
brightness settings so it's great for
using at night the build quality is
really solid and doesn't flex like other
cheaper Windows laptops do one thing we
can complain about is that there's no
notch in the front to help open the
laptop so you kind of have to jam your
fingernail in there to open it up and
the hinge itself is pretty stiff so it's
tough to open with one hand the trackpad
is also pretty good for a Windows laptop
but you definitely won't get the same
experience as with one of the newer Mac
books which feature the best track pads
in the business but the XPS 13 trackpad
is still above average one thing that
really stands out about the new XPS 13
is that it packs a total of three full
speed USB seaports with two of them
supporting full speed Thunderbolt 3 a
lot of other Windows laptops only come
with one full speed Thunderbolt 3 port
or two slower ones so having two full
speed ports is impressive it also packs
a mini SD card slot a headphone jack in
a neat little battery indicator that
shows you your current battery life one
thing that still disappoints us
year-over-year is the speaker quality it
sounds ok but it
definitely lacks volume in a wide range
of frequency reproduction
[Music]
a few years ago these types of speakers
were the norm but many windows Aptos
have been making big improvements the
720p webcam actually isn't too bad using
noise reduction to make for a clearer
but not a sharp image but the microphone
quality was really terrible just listen
for yourself this is a microphone
quality tests on the Dell XPS 13 this is
a microphone quality test on the MacBook
Pro on the plus side
battery life is also really impressive
compared to last year but that's using
the default battery saving settings if
you leave it on these settings you'll
get decent performance similar to the
base 13 inch dual-core MacBook Pro which
is not what you'd expect from its I 5
quad-core processor but if you turn on
best performance mode you'll gain a lot
of extra processing power and we saw the
same results for the graphics as well
compared to last year we're getting a
ton of graphics performance this is
probably one of the biggest standout
features of this laptop it's really
powerful for the price so can handle
things like entry-level video or photo
editing really well and even simple 4k
video editing however we're a bit
disappointed with the nvme storage speed
it's not too bad but we really hope
it'll speed up next year but either way
if you're someone who's looking for a
good quality laptop with great
performance for around the $1000 range
the Dell XPS 13 is a good choice it's a
great laptop overall with only a couple
of downsides that many regular users may
not mind and at a price of just $1,150
it's a really good value but if your
sewin will be using the soft top in a
bright environment or watching a lot of
video content and music you might want
to look elsewhere huawei mate book X pro
would be a great alternative but with
everything that's been going on with
huawei recently it's a tough sell if
you've got some extra cash definitely
look into the 4k model of the XPS 13 or
maybe even one of the higher-end XPS 15
models which packs dedicated graphics
and six core processors if you're also
considering buying an Apple MacBook you
should definitely check out our
comparison between the XPS 13 and the
base 13 inch MacBook Pro right there
make sure to smash that like button and
click the circle above to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]